the show begins 20 courses the pricetag
1000 and 500 euros per person each
course has a new setting on the Spanish
island of Ibiza what is probably the
world's most expensive restaurant offers
a dining extravaganza
guests enjoy the first culinary offering
at the door the entry ticket tastes like
chocolate and lime sublimation seats a
maximum of 12 people they experience
surprise after surprise in rapid
succession 6 cameras observe the guests
the room is changed by computer with
lighting effects smells wind and smoke
hidden behind glass the team controls
the show the show begin with caviar
oysters and champagne of course here the
soil is edible a mixture of chopped
black olives and bread the culinary
artists expect the 20 courses to take a
total of 3 hours their concept is
successful the restaurant is fully
booked for months in advance
[Music]
oh it's lovely seafood dishes are served
up in an underwater world it's an
expensive treat
[Music]
ha
some of them will just be honest when
Imai
[Music]
technical innovations are part of
popcorn Saros concept here he tests a
pair of virtual reality glasses can a
flight simulator alter the taste
experience on a simulated trip on the
orient express.the table even vibrates
the mushroom dish is thematically staged
to Ibiza is known the world over as a
party island that provides inspirations
for Paco drone saddles show
[Music]
there's a setting recalling Ibiza in the
1960s and a desert that revolves on a
record on a turntable experiential
dining is a playground for the cooks and
guests alike think you think you think
you think
[Music]
here a chef composes his culinary
creations like a painter the food
changes color and texture before the
diners eyes all their senses are
involved
[Music]
head chef Paco and cerro fitz guests
farewell from a movie screen what a
spectacular performance
[Music]